[Music]
good afternoon welcome to Patel Chapel
I'm sorry it's toasty with the
permission of the family I will give
your permission after the after the
initial speaker to take off your jacket
if you feel comfortable that way welcome
to this service in memory and in
celebration of a live Cesar Pelli on
behalf of the family I welcome you here
as Caesar's friends colleagues and
students we gather still with a deep
sense of loss but also at the beginning
of a time when we can share stories and
memories of a remarkable life we gather
to welcome each other with the kinship
of each of your experiences and memories
of Cesar and the acceptance that each of
us will feel that loss differently I
know this is an audience of many
different religious backgrounds but
while those who wish please join me in
prayer
gather us together this afternoon a
community of celebration and memory that
we might share together how one life
touched and changed each of our lives
give us generosity of spirit light
hearts and gratitude for so many gifts
now it's my pleasure to introduce Peter
Salome the 23rd president of Yale
good afternoon on behalf of the Pelle
family and on behalf of the Yale family
I welcome you to this service for a
wonderful architect committed New Haven
citizen and a beloved member of the
university community there will be
people speaking today who knew Cesar
well over many years and who will
describe in detail and with passion his
work and his life but I want to say a
few words about what it means to yell to
have Cesar on campus than in our home
city yell is the only university of its
kind to have four schools of the Arts
and their presence is critical at Yale
the arts are a fundamental part of life
and helped shape our identity the
stature of the deans who lead these
schools their standing in the profession
their leadership what they model to our
students to the Yale community and to
the world more broadly is of tremendous
institutional significance
Cesar honored Yale in many ways but
first as a Dean of the School of
Architecture his tenure coincided with a
critical moment in his architectural
practice and yet he gave himself wholly
to the task but Cesar's leadership
through his deanship were only one of
his gifts to yell on a little Street
across from the British Art Center Cesar
along with Fred Clark and later
Raphael built Pelli Clarke Pelli and did
an outwardly unprepossessing edifice
some of the greatest buildings in the
world
were planned wide-eyed students taken
for a visit across the street were
transported to New York or China or
Kuala Lumpur
they viewed the models under
construction amazed that all this could
be happening in this small city above
architectural unremarkable Chapel Street
stores Pelli Clarke Pelli also built
beautiful Yale buildings including one
triumph soon to be dedicated but perhaps
most important to all of yellow and New
Haven was not just that Pelli Clarke
Pelli was here or that his buildings
were here but that Caesar himself was
here no matter how famous no matter how
important he became no matter how far he
traveled no matter what great buildings
he and Pelli Clarke Pelli built no
matter what urbane and sophisticated
people he knew Caesar always seemed
delighted to have this place as his
hometown he loved New Haven he loved
that travel between the school of
architecture and his firm was seamless
just down the street he was a New Haven
householder with a summer home on the
shoreline he was a community member who
could walk the streets and greet people
with a memorable smile he especially
loved the faculty until he grew older
and it was harder for him to hear well
he frequented a club that met in
Jonathan Edwards college distinguished
faculty members came together to discuss
history literature and science all of
which he was deeply interested in and
all of which captivated his imagination
he truly was a member of the New Haven
and Yale families Seeger Cesar's
legendary warmth and down-to-earth charm
his laughter his generosity and his
ability to make everyone in his presence
feel better about themselves made him a
valued community member
it is wonderful to have brilliant deans
and faculty at a university it is even
more remarkable for them to be beloved
community citizens as well with enduring
gratitude to the Pelley family to
Raphael and Denis and their families to
Pelli Clarke Pelli to all who work in
the firm New Haven and in New York and
to all who admired and loved Cesar I
welcome you here to Battelle today
whether you are on the livestream in
Argentina China Kuala Lumpur across the
camp campus and Lindsley Chittenden or
in this room itself we can all draw
together as a community of memory and
hope in our regard and affection for
Cesar may those memories be blessings
Thank You Reverend Oliver Thank You
president Salome and thank you all of
you for being here today in the family
Rafael and I called my father Caesar or
by his nickname tato
I remember Caesar always there always
happy always playful I remember her
teaching me to play chess he taught me
to always focus on the king it was fun
to play with him
his advice always seemed very plain just
common sense not so much a rule as an
easy deduction from the facts of the
situation my parents
Gianna and Caesar Vienna Balamory were
very close they talked about the world
and ideas they talked about how things
look when I was with them typically we'd
be walking even in LA where nobody walks
and they would often point out something
like look at that tree against the sky
it's handsome and then we try to say why
it looks so good and that is why I
became a vision scientist to try and
answer those questions
Caesar Indiana lived almost their whole
lives together Caesar was born and grew
up in tucumán we have the governor of
tucumán with us today Dooku man is the
fifth largest city in Argentina it was
founded in 1565 by the Spanish
conquistador Diego the BT royal when
Caesar was growing up the main industry
was sugar from sugar cane everyone got
around by tram we all lived there for a
year when I was six and I remember the
treat of chewing a piece of sugarcane to
cumin is semi-tropical it can hit a
hundred and fifteen degrees the streets
are lined with orange trees and when
they bloom the whole city has the orange
scent Cesar's maternal grandmother was
indigenous of the yogeeta people I met
her when I was six and she was in her
80s she had long black hair and she
wrung the net
of my grandfather's rooster in
preparation for a feast she married an
Italian immigrant Caesars paternal
grandparents also came from Italy the
wife followed the husband years later
and tracked him down to do coumadin
Caesars mother Teresa grew up very poor
but became a teacher and later founded
several elementary schools ceases father
worked in the city government and later
during the war manufactured and sold
glue which he called belly Cola
in English that would be Pelle glue he
taught me carpentry the Anna's parents
were Spanish and English they fled Spain
during the Civil War and they came to
tucumán in 1940 in one of the last boats
as World War two began Caesars mother
Teresa and Diana's mother Dorothy both
taught at the escuela Sarmiento and
Elementary in high school associated
with the University and they quickly
became good friends this was about 1940
when Cesar was fourteen and Deanna was
eight the family sometimes went on
holidays together the parents decided
early that Cesar Indiana were a good
match and indeed they did eventually
marry in 1950 do come and had a good
University Caesar and Dianna both
studied architecture there several
teachers including sacristy had fled the
Spanish Civil War and brought modernism
to Takuma me Cesar told me how excited
he was by Mondrian and the clean lines
of modernism he came back home and
explained to his parents that all the
decorative details in their furniture at
home were superfluous and he convinced
his father to cut them off on reflection
forty years later he was embarrassed
about this
Cesar used to play cards with his
friends and he was good at poker
his brother Victor said that when Cesar
won he'd share by giving him a present
and he said he still has one of those
presents Cesar told me that his friends
were sure he'd be a professional poker
player they were very surprised when he
became an architect he told me that he
never played poker again after leaving
Argentina when Cesar and Diana got
married and
come on Caesar had received a fellowship
to do a master's at University of
Illinois but they needed money to pay
for the Anna's ticket so the day after
the wedding they secretly went to town
and sold all the wedding presents they
came to Illinois and I was soon born
there the transition to USA was dramatic
cuckoo - semi-tropical and their parents
or middle class at the University of
Illinois the winter was bitter and they
were broke they lived in a one-room
Quonset hut that the University offered
to international students it was heated
by a coal burning stove Cesar told me
that one day the stove was burning too
hot so he opened it and threw in a pail
of water
oops the water exploded and he was
thrown against the opposite wall covered
with burning embers dianna took him to
emergency and thanks to a magic cream he
got no scars they had no money they told
me that it took them ten years to pay
the obstetrician for my easy birth to
eat they would cut out discount coupons
and thank God a local grocery accepted
coupons without regard to what the item
was so they paid with just coupons no
cash as a treat they would go to a local
diner and buy a cup of coffee they
became good friends with another couple
their Myrtle and Joe Silva who became my
godparents for the first Thanksgiving
several families put their money
together to buy a turkey which dionan
Caesar cooked when everyone sat at the
table they asked where the gravy was
Theon and Caesar asked what that was
they had already discarded all the juice
from the pan even fifty years later they
were embarrassed because the others were
so disappointed but they had no idea
that people saved the juice Caesar his
first job was working with Eero Saarinen
in Bloomfield Hills Michigan all I
remember of that time was learning to
swim and ride a bike and my parents
showing us how to pour molten lead into
water to produce amazing shapes years
later I remember our family visiting the
TWA terminal at JFK that the Cernan
office designed at that time it hadn't
opened yet so the runways were not yet
in service so we were
to drive on it on the runway and we went
very fast
the sarahdan office moved here to New
Haven and we moved with it sometimes
Cesar would bring us to work and give us
a table and paper and pencils to draw
with during that time the onion Cesar
used to read to us after dinner from the
Odyssey
one book a night we all loved it so we
followed with the Iliad but we all got
bored with the order of battle a very
long list of who came from where Caesar
and Rafael and I drew a lot sometimes we
got clay from a local clay pit and we
made sculptures usually animals we also
made masks from paper mache after seeing
some impressive ancient Greek more masks
then Caesar took a job at daniel man
Johnson and Mendel Hall dim Jim in Los
Angeles he told me that his colleagues
told him that this would be a terrible
mistake because the contracts the firm
worked under were focused on costs not
great architecture but in fact he did
great architecture on a budget there's a
12 volume history of the world by Arnold
Toynbee I remember Caesar reading at
volume by volume until he reached the
end no matter what time or place old
caesar always seemed to know what had
happened there caesar indiana were great
parents when i introduced them to my
friends my friends wanted to be adopted
caesar was very focused on his work but
it never took over he was always home
for dinner and on weekends and Rafael
and I saw him every day and he was
always fun to be with Rafael will tell
you more soon I want to thank my cousin
Marga Victor Caesars brother for help
with the history thank you
[Music]
hi I'm Mariana I am scissors tato nice
and we have a tradition in our family
and it is to when somebody passes in the
family we sing for them poems of the
death of his father by Jorge Manrique
who died in 1479 my grandmother Dorothy
sang it for my grandfather for our
grandfather
dianna sang it for Dorothy I for my
father
and for Diana and now for Cesar record
el alma dormido of evil say sue is a
spirit a contemplando como se passe à la
vita como se viene la muerte tonka
Chando compressed au sable placer como
despues de corredor Dada
como nuestro para ser valkira tiempo
pasado we'll make
no estrous veto so los ríos give another
a la mejor que ser Maury high bar low
scenarios derecho subsea cavalry he
consumed me pudgy Los Rios called Alice
ha los otros Mariano CMAs G equals Raja
God of SonicWALL ins los que viven de
sus Manos he lost he
[Music]
este mundo es el camino para el otro
Keys Murata CMS are a mess complete
endure when t know where and are esta
Jornada sinner are a party Mo's cuando
NOS a most and damos mientras vivimos c
Giacomo's al tiempo chief any samos hace
que cuando more emos
there's concern
[Music]
[Music]
well good afternoon everybody I I want
to welcome everybody that I consider to
be the great Caesar Pelli an associates
Pelli Clarke Pelli family you know I'm
tempted to do something if you don't
mind I'll just take a minute anyone
who's ever worked for us in the past
present or works for us in currently
would you just mind standing for just a
second so we can see who all is here
[Applause]
a huge extended family emanating from
Caesar Indiana and the family trumpets
tremendous heritage we did a calculation
on Friday just to see how many people
we've employed over 42 years and it's
1197 jobs you can think of it that way
over the years which I'm extremely proud
of but you can call me employee number
one if you want to as some of you know I
met Caesar when I was still an
undergraduate at the University of Texas
at Austin I was still a year away from
graduating he came to school to give
lectures to participate in juries he saw
some of my work but honestly I don't
remember him seeing very much of my work
what I do remember is at a faculty party
after that wonderful day of juries I
walked across the lawn in these days
this was Austin before it became
discovered and sophisticated and
expensive this beautiful faculty lon
the crickets were chirping it was a
beautiful balmy evening and this these
gales of laughter were just rolling
across the grass and you can't help but
be attracted to gales of laughter so I
wandered over to the origin of this
wonderful sound and it was Diana Diana
was just she was just having such an
incredibly good time and so was Caesar
and this beautiful beautiful couple I'll
never forget the look of just this the
way they presented themselves we talked
about absolutely everything we talked
about everything but architecture they
were interested in everything they were
interested in music photography art we
talked mostly probably about the Beatles
and then the evening was over and I went
back to school to finish my to finish my
work for that semester and then almost
exactly a month later I got this
a letter from Ceaser dated in May 16
1969 I'm not gonna read the whole thing
to you because I won't be able to get
through it as you can tell but I was so
thrilled with this letter and it was
just so unusual I I'm still reading it
still trying to believe that it's real
even today I showed it to my father and
I said dad what should I do about this
and he said well obviously you have to
call him and see what the terms of
you're working for him are and my father
who was an extremely practically minded
person said and you have to ask three
questions and you have to do it exactly
this order and the answer to each
question gives you a sense of what the
answer to the next question might be the
three questions are number one what will
you be doing when you work for him he
said you have to be certain that you
have some value that you have something
to do because without value the other
two questions won't matter at all and he
said the second question is really easy
what's it gonna cost to live in Los
Angeles you know mind you I'd been
living in Austin Texas in the 60s which
was about the least expensive place that
one could possibly imagine living and he
said it's really important that you know
what you're getting yourself into
ask him how much it's going to cost to
live there and he said and finally sort
of depending on what those other two
answers are ask him how much you're
going to make so I called Cesar and I
got my first introduction to one of his
just gigantic last Oh Fred and he just
rolled with laughter good to hear you
grateful to hear from you I never
thought I'd hear from you he said and I
said Cesar may I ask you a few questions
and he said sure why not I mean that's
one of Cesar's patented phrases is sure
why not and I said well I have three
questions for you I'm not going to make
this quick I said first of all what will
I be doing when I moved to Los Angeles
to work for you he let out another who'd
of laughed he said I have no idea
you said I have absolutely no idea
he said just come we'll find something
for you to do I promise you don't worry
about it you'll have a job so I on the
back of the same piece of paper I'm kind
of keeping score and I I write low
answer to the first question
undetermined possibly zero the next
question was what's the cost of living
in 1969 in Los Angeles another peal of
laughter and he said oh gosh he said
probably today for you it would be $70 a
week and I thought well okay $70 a week
times roughly four weeks a month that's
two hundred and eighty dollars I said
okay now at least I know what my month
is going to cost and I finally I said
okay so what do you imagine I'll be
being paid I was being as indirect and
polite as I possibly could and asking
these tough questions and he said oh I
really don't know quite yet how about
four dollars an hour so a little bit
more mental math and I realized that
four dollars an hours roughly six
hundred and eighty six hundred and
ninety dollars a month I subtracted my
cost of living from that it looked like
I was gonna net at least on this piece
of paper three hundred dollars a month
and I thought well gee that's a lot of
money you know I can I can survive
pretty nicely on three hundred dollars a
month so I said I will be there when do
you want me there and he said how about
how about June 9th which was the subject
of this next card so I showed up on June
9th indeed they put me to work
immediately it was an absolutely
wonderful wonderful summer this was just
a summer job I worked with Arthur
Golding who's in the audience today some
of the brightest and most interesting
young designers I think in the
profession at that time was a very small
design department we did absolutely
everything together collaboration was
though was the way that we that we
socialized in the way that we worked
I was so gung-ho that I actually
volunteered to do things that I wasn't
even asked to do I made a point of
introducing myself to all of the
partners
imagine this is a summer job I said I
just in I just need for you guys to
Remember Who I am
I introduced myself to all the
department heads the project managers
and mind you in those days that the
project managers that grew and they
didn't really like architects at all and
so here was this young upstart
introducing himself forcing himself into
their lives the summer was over I went
to say goodbye to Caesar and to see if I
had a job in the future and he said he
sat me down and he said well you know
Fred he said you've done very very well
and we've noticed the energy and the
enthusiasm he said even though even the
project managers seem to like you which
is really unusual because they don't
even really like me that much and he
said so we welcome you back and he said
and you've really really contributed but
then he said I'll always remember this
he said you've really contributed not so
much in the way of ideas but you've
really contributed in the way of energy
and I thought to myself you know for $4
an hour I'm not gonna contribute ideas
you know I I D azar $6 an hour and good
ideas are $8 an hour so I knew who I
would start in terms of my salary when I
came back to to work with him Dan and we
worked together in LA for seven years
until moving to New Haven just one more
very funny story that's also very
typical of Caesar now let's fast-forward
20 years and let's go to Tokyo Japan
Caesar and I are there together our
partner in Japan Jun Matsui is also here
in the room today we finished a long
long day of meetings very successful
meeting somebody we are invited to a
wonderful Chi set a meal that evening
long evening and I think Caesar I was
going to probably be tired and ready to
go to the hotel by then but then one of
the young designer says how about
karaoke
okay I have never seen Caesar in a
karaoke bar in my whole life until that
one evening and he and of course he said
it in his patented way
sure why not and if all of a sudden his
energy level just just escalated we went
to the karaoke bar if you've ever been
to karaoke you know the first thing that
happens is that you're given this giant
catalogue of song titles that you sift
through and choose the title you want he
jerked it out of my hand I thought oh my
gosh we're gonna have to sing in Spanish
or something this is this is gonna be a
disaster he thumped through it and one
of our hosts said that's the one that's
the one you should do right there and I
looked at it and I said oh my gosh we
can't possibly do that song that's the
hardest karaoke song in the book nobody
can sing that song and I said I don't
think it's I think it's gonna be a
failure and he said but we have to do it
because our guests are insisting that we
sing this exact song and I said it's I
said Caesar it's super-hard let's try to
do something else I said you like the
Beatles let's do rocky raccoon and he
said you know I sing rocky raccoon all
the time I'm I'm kind of tight I kind of
tired of that song in the lyric so silly
anyway you say we're gonna do what these
guys tell us to do so the two of us walk
up to the stage to two guys that's you
know you're bathed in the lavender light
of of a karaoke bar it's surreal in and
of itself you've got two guys with it
let's say charitably in my in my in my
view at least 1/8 inch height difference
microphones in our hands I'm thinking to
myself this is a lot like waiting Godot
the musical you know this is this is
gonna be really stupid so we get up and
then our host hits the karaoke button
and this is what it sounds like
[Music]
and I just start collapsing and I say
Caesar you know he said he said I got a
deal for you
you sing the verses and I'll sing the
chorus okay now if anybody knows that
song don't stop believin it's all verses
there's that there's only one chorus and
the course is at the very very end and I
don't know if he can do that or not but
so I'm I'm the music starts I'm singing
and I'll tell you what I just I own this
song
I own this song I do such a good job I
impress even myself now a good karaoke
machine will make anybody sound like a
good singer but that night I was really
on fire so I was I was working it I was
doing it to the verses I went through
verse number three the chorus is coming
up
I looked there the courses about to
appear and I looked to my left to say
okay Caesar it's about time for the
chorus and there was no Caesar and I
looked around behind me and there it was
Caesar at the table drinking another
glass of sake doing this kind of doing
this wave that those of us who know him
so well
know he did really he said great
marvelous fantastic
and and I said but you're supposed to do
the chorus he said no no no that song
was way way way too hard and then he
said we should have done rocky raccoon
so that was the that was our karaoke
experience and I think some of you have
witnessed that yourselves
what what I will say though is I visited
with him last May on the anniversary of
this letter the 50th anniversary of this
letter and I sat with him to thank him
for everything that he had done for me I
showed him this letter he let one very
last voluminous laugh and he said I
don't know what no coy how to take this
he said oh did I write that letter and I
said well gee I hope so I mean I didn't
I don't know I don't know I didn't write
this letter he said oh my god she said
Fred fifty years my gosh where did it go
and I said I have absolutely no idea but
it's the best 50 years anyone could have
ever spent in his life and I thank you
very much my friend
[Applause]
gentle graceful elegant these words
define Caesar Pelley's aesthetic as an
architect and his manner as a person
although Caesar lived a mere 200 yards
from our house in New Haven I didn't
have the pleasure of meeting him until
1993 when the remodeled and expanded
headquarters of the Yale University
Press were dedicated at the time neither
of us had any premonition of the
important role that Caesar would play in
rebuilding the Yale campus over the
quarter century that followed he
designed the graceful Landman Center
addition to the Payne Whitney gymnasium
the jewel-like Malone Engineering Center
the splendid Thomas golden Center at st.
Thomas More and the Magnificent new Yale
science building Caesar and Fred Clark
also designed the elegant Yale and u.s.
College campus in Singapore you might be
surprised that I would use the word
graceful to describe a large addition to
the massive Payne Whitney gymnasium
housing for basketball courts and an
elegant and an elevated running track
but graceful it is because Caesar had
the ingenious idea of putting half of
the height of the building below ground
stepping down to a friendly engagement
with late place and providing abundant
above-ground fenestration to illuminate
the interior and lighten the exterior
and perhaps the word elegant seems an
odd word choice for a Yale and u.s.
college that houses 1,000 students in
residential colleges provides offices
for 250 faculty and staff both and
boasts a library a Student Center a
Performing Arts Center a gym a dance
studio science labs 40 classrooms and
abundant green space all on a 10 acre
site but elegant it is because Caesar
saw almost instantly
that he could maintain the look and feel
of Yale residential colleges by
constructing quadrangles of graceful
low-rise buildings around green
courtyards and with a clever local
adaptation the classrooms and faculty
offices are located in the low-rise
buildings while within the colleges
while students are housed in high-rise
towers at the corners of the quadrangles
lush tropical and gleaming white the
college is at once Singaporean and
unmistakably Yale it was a privilege to
work with Cesar and his colleagues on
these projects over the years but his
contribution to Yale went far beyond his
own designs a few years after I became
president we asked Cesar Tom Beebe and
Bob Stern to serve as a design review
committee to offer advice on all of our
major projects as well as on our ongoing
master planning Cesar loved these
meetings in part I think because he so
loved the Yale campus it's rich mix of
architectural traditions the interplay
among its buildings and its urban
setting we think of Caesar as a
modernist but in the context of
renovating the Yale campus he had
exquisite sensitivity in distinguishing
which buildings required reverent
restoration and which called out for
intervention and innovation Cesar also
understood which new buildings or
additions needed to be understated and
deferential to adjacent masterpieces and
which could be bold dramatic and
original some architects dreaded the
prospect of subjecting their work to
reviews by three Dean's of the Yale
architecture school but Cesar's comments
even if radically critical in substance
were offered
Oh gently so respectfully that they were
often embraced without resistance and it
seemed to me there was a common thread
in many of Cesar's comments lighten it
up it's too heavy make it more graceful
more elegant drive by Cesar's new Yale
science building on Whitney Avenue and
you will see what I mean it's a huge
building but set against Philip
Johnson's massive monuments it seems to
float on air very few of the 40
buildings built over my 20 years as
president rise to this level but dozens
of Yale buildings new and renovated bear
the mark of Caesars gentle graceful and
elegant advice for me working with
Caesar was a joy his eye was unerring
and his taste exquisite he was a superb
listener attentive and sympathetic even
his laughter was generous his
characteristic ho-ho might be be mused
but never mocking his buildings the
fruits of his genius our gifts to cities
and campuses around the world how
fortunate are we citizens of Yale and
New Haven that he was ours
I'm honored to be here today and you
know I have to say when I look out in
the audience I feel like we were all
kids together we all grew up in that
office we all learned so much in our
early formative years and so I was
really honored when Raphael asked me to
speak today and to reflect on my
memories of this remarkable and generous
man in the last 40 years
I knew Caesar as a Yale Dean a teacher
an employer a mentor a humanist always a
humanist a father figure and a friend 18
of those years I've spent in this firm
in the last 22 of them I've been working
on my own firm with my partner Jeff
Payne at each phase of my career
Caesars words of wisdom have resonated
for me and brought me insight his wisdom
is always present when Raphael asked me
to speak from personal experience
and occurred to me to read a letter that
I have written Caesar a few years back I
used to do this periodically I didn't
get a letter from him but I kept sending
in letters and I tried to share with him
what was in my heart and what I learned
from him
dear Caesar if we are really fortunate
in life we are blessed to have
encountered great teachers mentors and
fantastic leaders seizure you are all of
these it began in our formative years
when you taught us the value of your
Socratic design process as you led us
through inquiry you taught us that we
should be judged by the quality of the
questions that we asked and oftentimes
with each of those hundreds of design
models that we all built and we're all
thinking to ourselves the night before
you're going to present the seas or your
thinking is
the right solution and I still remember
Caesar would look at your model and he
would look at you and he would go that
is a very good question and the
questions were valuable because that
question led to the next question which
led to the right answer I love the story
with you as my mentor the story that you
told about Eero Saarinen as your mentor
when he came to the studio with the
drawing in his hand of a design he'd
been working on and asked the design
team what they thought when everyone
around the table who was a little
intimidated they were completely silent
heroes simply crumpled up the drawing
and told the team start anew how
liberating you two would come to a
design problem with no preconceived
ideas it opened the door for all of us
to participate in the search for the
right solution how empowering is that as
we matured and learned about your world
of ideas we learned that it was not
enough to help solve the architectural
problem
I remember presenting a scheme for one
of your projects to you with utmost
clarity and logic and you said well it
all looks very logical and it all works
but is it beautiful and how will it be
experienced that was a great reminder
that in the end the architecture must
stand on its own with no explanation
other than what it can contribute to
society it's also a moment that I
realized that your architecture was
shaped by a set of values and not
theories guiding principles as you
called them that had been acquired
through years of experience it was these
guiding principles that allowed us to
grow our wings within your firm and
build our own sense of car
evidence as a diverse set of designers
it was after I left you and built my own
firm with Jeff that you shared perhaps
your greatest advice you asked if I was
teaching you've said it's vitally
important to surround yourself with
talented intelligent young people for
they will keep you fresh and give your
work longevity Cesar I still carry with
me the many lessons I learned while
working with you the respect you have
earned and the respect you have given to
others continues to be attributes that I
strive for every day with you as my
model your wisdom will always follow me
in my work in my practice warmest
regards Tehran I should also add and I
appreciate there's going to be lots of
references to Cesar's laughter and it's
laughter to me was his way of opening up
his soul to other people and he had a
wicked sense of humor I remember one
time I had this conversation with him
and I said Cesar I have to tell you
there used to be this old show called
kung foo and on that show there was a
young guy who had you know grown up and
he always remembered what the great
master told him and young grasshopper
would go to the master and ask him
important questions and you remind me of
that every time I think of you Cesar and
he said that's wonderful to run just
don't shave your head
so Cesar you'll be missed but you'll
never be forgotten because you're such a
sweet sweet and inspiring man
eleventh elegy beginning the spring
chores by Nikita Stannis school I shall
run everywhere at once after my own
heart
I shall run like a chariot in battle
pulled everywhere at once by a herd of
galloping horses I shall run until the
forward rush the rush it itself will
surpass me and leave me far behind like
fruit peel from seed till running itself
starts running and stops I'll then
collapse like a young man greeting his
lover Here I am remaining what I am
under flags of solitude under shields of
cold running back towards myself tearing
me from everywhere tearing me from
forward tearing me from behind from the
right and from my left from above and
beneath me leaving from everywhere and
gifting everywhere roots to memory stars
for the skies air for earth green lifts
branches for the shadows
goodbye scissor
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
as you set out for Ithaca hope your road
is a long one full of adventure full of
discovery Lystra go nians cyclops angry
poseidon don't be afraid of them
you'll never find things like that on
your way as long as you keep your
thoughts raised high as long as a rare
excitement stirs your spirit and your
body leister go nians cyclops wild
poseidon you won't encounter them unless
you bring them along inside your soul
unless your soul sets them up in front
of you hope your road is a long one may
there be many summer mornings when with
what pleasure
what joy you enter harbors you're seeing
for the first time may you stop it
Phoenician trading stations to buy fine
things
mother of pearl and coral amber and
ebony sensual perfume of every kind as
many sensual perfumes as you can and may
you visit many Egyptian cities to learn
and go on learning from their scholars
keep ethica always in your mind
arriving there is what you're destined
for but don't hurry the journey at all
better if it lasts for years so you're
old by the time you reach the island
wealthy with all you've gained on the
way not expecting Ithaca to make you
rich ethica gave you the marvelous
journey without her you wouldn't have
set out she has nothing left to give you
now and if you find her poor Ithaca
won't have fooled you wise as you will
have become so full of experience you'll
have understood by then what these
Ithaca's mean
[Music]
it's an honor to be with you all today
to remember and celebrate Cesar Pelli I
will be talking about the school the
students and the faculty on whom Caesar
had tremendous and meaningful impact it
it's slightly different part of Caesars
life than Fred and Rick and Taryn spoke
about but it's inevitable that I'll also
mention as they did his elegance and
grace his talent and intelligence his
generosity and kindness and his laugh
which I can't begin to imitate Caesar
was a gifted architect and a thoughtful
one but I knew him as an architectural
educator and that was something he did
exceptionally well in preparing for
these remarks in my office which was
once his office at Yale I found an old
photograph of Caesar probably taken
around 40 years ago he is sitting on a
review a classic school of architecture
event and it reminded me of how I
remembered Caesar when I was junior
faculty he was no longer Dean but very
present at the school he was serious and
engaged smiling warmly but intensely
focused on the design in front of him it
documented what I had witnessed and also
what so many alumni told me in the days
after his death to a-1 they said
Caesar cared about me and my work you
can see that care in this photograph he
is happy to be surrounded by students
and designers people working on
something he cared passionately about
architecture that care continued for all
of them who stayed in touch and they
mentioned that as well some went to work
for Pelli Clarke Pelli a thousand more
some went to work in Chicago or la
others moved halfway around the world
but if they saw Caesar or contacted him
he remembered them their work their
designs and their lives they were part
of an extended family of Yale trained
architects and he had nurtured them all
without affection and support extended
to faculty as well and went beyond
architecture to life and for you non
architects in the room this is actually
exceptional that an architect care about
life beyond just designing buildings in
my life
it included his critical yet supportive
comments on my first buildings and I
believe the phrase he used to describe
them was they were citrus tart wasn't
sure if that was a compliment or not he
was also interested in my family and
when I got married Caesar and Diana sent
two small elegant modern blown glass
pitchers the kind you'd put on the table
if you were serving breakfast maybe to
Jackie Kennedy or to Caesar Pelli for
that matter we still have them and when
asked where did you get those beautiful
things I say with pride they were a
wedding present from Caesar Pelli and
Diana Balmore II as with other faculty
members Caesar would occasionally invite
me to lunch at his office go up the
steep stairs see what he was curious
about that day he was curious and
interested in what the students were
doing and most especially what they were
interested in and when I became Dean
those lunches became more frequent how
Caesar is it that for Dean's and 35
years later he was still so passionate
and interested in the school
Caesars warmth and generosity and his
unforgettable laugh have been mentioned
as I said I'm delighted to be the one to
note that Caesar was also chic and
perhaps all the more chic because he
didn't really focus at all on being chic
what was practical elegant and
understated for Caesar was the
definition of personal chic miss it self
to me as an observer he had a style that
went from the scale of inches v-neck
sweaters beneath a tweed jacket the
oversized eyeglasses and his white bra
and watch all the way to the skyline
shaping profile of the twin petronas
towers at more than 1400 feet now that's
a tall expansive chic pyrrha chic and he
was brilliantly talented but it was his
vision and his engagement his defense of
the strength and value of the place that
had the greatest impact on the school
Caesar was supportive of young
architects
and of women having careers in
traditionally male-dominated fields like
architecture and I'm sure I'm not the
only one here got both a wedding present
and helpful advice on how to get the
next big Commission Raphael and Dennis
and everyone in the Pelle family Fred
Susannah and everyone at Pelli Clarke
Pelli Caesars work family on behalf of
the School of Architecture Caesars
extended family at the corner of York
and Chapel how blessed are we all to
have had Caesar in our lives his gifted
hand and designed vision were valuable
having his wise counsel to help shape a
global practice or direct a school of
architecture with a global reputation
that feels irreplaceable he was a good
man a generous soul and a spirited sage
Godspeed dear Caesar brilliant architect
inspired educator superb Dean and true
friend
[Applause]
[Music]
my deepest condolences to Raphael and
Dennis this is special time in my life
I'm proud to be here today I'd like to
express a few ideas that I thought about
related to your dad that I think you'll
enjoy Cesar and I first met in 1993 when
I was on a panel to interview the three
architects owens-corning
had shortlisted to design the new world
headquarters that was planned for Toledo
Ohio Cesar was like a breath of fresh
air you could see how much he loved and
enjoyed his work visiting his firm on
numerous to work on projects Marilyn and
I would come loaded down with sketches
and class studies carrying up the steep
stairs to his office where he would help
us unwrap them excitedly calling in
others to view Cesar loved materials and
shared his delight and enthusiasm I
remember early on bringing an
electroluminescent encapsulated art
glass panel for a lighting application
we were working on I asked him when he
wanted to see if it worked he said sure
so imagine this panel with this gadget
in it with these wires that I had
sticking out the end and Cesar said yeah
let's try it so we went out of the
conference room we went to another room
and we found some outlets along the
floor a note Tehran and mr. shoemaker
was there and so I plug it into those
two little openings in the socket and it
started to light up it was glowing then
it started to spark and that smoke came
out then everybody got up I looked
around and Caesar what had been looking
right over the project looked back and
Cesar's totally at the opposite end of
the room then he said and this should be
memorialized this thing he said great
time great but Wow
vermin it was always that he couldn't
get enough of my artwork in the building
and he kept coming up with ideas that we
could try in hindsight it was true
collaboration Cesar knew what he knew
and he knew what I didn't know
he said that collaboration forces you to
stretch yourself he was bold when I
hesitated about my work dominating the
space he said that he would never
compromise the integrity of the project
and that my art would make it more
meaningful experience for the people
using the building I used to think of
our friendship Seder centered on art and
architecture but in many of the letters
to us I am reminded when he spoke about
one winters in New Haven I have similar
feelings about the snow he wrote it is
irritating when I shoveled it when my
car gets stuck when my feet get wet but
I love what it does to the garden and to
all the landscape is one of the reasons
that I prefer the changing New England
weather to reliable sunny California he
wrote about the time away from New Haven
last week Diana and I took a short
holiday in London we went to every
exhibition in play we could get in and
came back replenished
during the summer Maryland I had a
vegetable garden and we would bring
things from our garden and we're
visiting his studio but it was the
garlic we grew that reminded him of his
childhood in Argentina he said your
garlic smells like roses to meet Tom is
Shelby thoroughly enjoy very fast
unfortunately I hate to say it but only
the guy only garlic I get is the
ordinary one from the market nothing
like yours I don't believe there is any
garlic as tasty as the one you have been
so kind of giving me for so many years I
can still see him standing at the top of
the stairs as we left
don't forget the garlic his letters
would end I am very well and very busy
and those two things to go together I
hope you two are also busy and well that
was Caesar a man who appreciated and
loved many things with a passion for
life family friends and his work a
passion that he shared he will be missed
thank you
[Applause]
it is so nice to see so many familiar
faces in the audience and it makes me
feel that we are truly a unique family
it's also very nice to see so many
representatives of the Argentine
community and we are really very honored
to have you here
Cesar would say that Argentina was a big
part of who he was and I would like to
take a moment to explain what Cesar
meant to Argentina by telling a short
story so two years ago
Argentina presented a bid to host the
2023 International Expo in Buenos Aires
with a video highlighting the best
Argentina had to offer to the world the
video displayed the natural splendor of
Patagonia the art of the asados and the
Poissy of the tango the attention then
was turned to the people that make
Argentina so special highlight into the
world the the magnificence of Messi and
the holiness of the Pope and then it
showed Caesar with a skyline of when
Osiris and the four handsome buildings
that are now part of his legacy although
Messi and the Pope are very popular they
can also generate very divided opinions
but when it comes to Caesar everyone
agreed that he was the best beyond his
buildings Argentines really learned to
admire that he never changed he's
down-to-earth attitude or his gratitude
to the school of tucumán who foreign
pain I started to work in this office 27
years ago and two months later Cesar was
commissioned to design his first
building in Argentina so I had the
unique chance to travel with him from
very early on
traveling with Caesar to Argentina was
always a pleasure but it was seldom an
easy task I very soon learned that part
of my job was to protect Caesar from the
reporters and the frenzied crowds
waiting for him after each and every one
of the many lectures that he offered
there in this effort my best Ally was
Carlos Caesar's younger brother with his
exceptional humility and sense of humor
Caesar would turn to us and job that he
had no idea that he was signing for that
when he chose to become an architect
Caesar was very humble but there were
two things that he liked to brag about
with me the first one was punished
he was totally convinced that he Spanish
was better than mine we will settle our
differences by checking constantly his
Spanish dictionary and we mask up in
both very stubborn because it took us
several years to admit that neither of
us spoke proper Spanish he spoke to
kumano and I spoke for taenia secondly
there was tango Cesar and I could not
sing but we both like to recite tango we
never settled who was better at that but
I should have told him that I really
admired that he could be so good at
reciting tango when actually looking at
the past with nostalgia was not his
style
he will always remember his childhood
and youth in tucumán with pure joy and
even a sense of wonder on how his life
had turned out to be as a teacher
Cesar extended his hand to many
architectural school
sinn Argentina establishing internship
programs with several of them in the
history of our office we had about 30
Argentine employees and there are
currently six of us but regardless of
nationality or any other label Cesar
embraced everyone in his studio as part
of his extended family he valued all of
us as individuals and he made the time
to get to know our spouses significant
others and our children when I was
working on Cesar second building in
Argentina I became a mother of twins and
I found really hard to juggle
architecture and motherhood
I told Cesar that I had gained fully
decided to give up on architecture but
he was really determined to make things
work for me even offering to babysit my
kids though he never got to do that I'm
here today mainly because of his
relentless support Cesar Cesar had a
tradition of making this beautiful
pastel sketches for four clients as a
way of showing his appreciation for
their help to get these buildings built
and so when we were designing our third
tower in one Esaias Cesar did one of
these beautiful sketches and as I was
still working a few days a week from
home he sent the pastel home with my
husband who also works with us and so we
were looking together at the pastel when
one of our kids walks into the room and
he points out very disappointedly
that the tower
was incomplete and the truth was that
Caesar had left out too narrow strips to
the side of our tower that in my son's
mind in May the tower looked like a
rocket ready to take off
so I told these of the story and we both
laughed but a few days later he calls me
into his office and I found him standing
up pointing out to a new Buster on his
wall and with a big smile on his face he
says Susana you can tell me Cal that his
tower is ready to take off once again he
had written the sketch taking the advice
of a five-year-old boy and then he and
paint the pastel and gave it to me to
bring home I'm talking to people in our
studio I know there are two things about
Caesar that we all miss the most his
mentorship and his laughter when we
finished our fourth building in
Argentina the first building changed
ownership and suffered some alterations
in my mind the result was not very
flattering and so I walked into Caesars
office to break the bad news to him and
Caesar listen to me very attentively and
then he said well Susana I see that we
have two options here we can cry or we
can laugh and then laughing loudly as
only he could he said I choose to laugh
as I needed some explanation and then he
continued Susana our buildings are like
our children we have to love them
all the same we help them grow but they
really do not belong to us we have to
learn to let them go as hard as it is I
know today is my turn to learn to let
you go
adios Macario say sir
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
muchacho marina their catch of tiempos
toka me om printer Loretta Arthur the
wall economy would muchacha Mucha boy he
may racing let me know para me toda la
[Music]
Pharisee temples tiempos de lo bueno
mementos can't on your digital circuit
Rav MA
Sita Sita tree my sincerity yells amigos
[Music]
Tommy and is your tiempos vitoca be om
printer and Loretta Dada
Monica made me will know who to tell
how do you know
Dino no Leela gotta say let me know
don't bother me so that my father owes
me what if I'm better born overseas
[Music]
[Applause]
Razia mañana Dania gracias al que Lindo
somewhere Cesar was singing along to the
tango he loved the tangles as I was
trying to remember my father and put my
thoughts together I was helped by many
of you and hundreds and hundreds of
notes and cards and phone calls and
emails you all sent me with condolences
sympathies but a lot of lovely anecdotes
and stories and there were certain words
that were repeated again and again
gracious distinguished kind and he was
all those things and he was many more he
was an adventurer and he lived an
adventurous life and you heard some of
that from Denis when my brother is
growing up and took cumin coming to the
Midwest for ten years then going to New
Haven then Los Angeles and back to Yale
and as a true adventurer much as the
poem that Kate read about ethica he
enjoyed the journey and enjoyed every
stop and he took savored the best of
every stop along the way he wrote a
beautiful autobiography in a series of
essays to my two daughters very personal
and one of the things he wrote in it was
I was unquestionably lucky I took
several leaps into the unknown he wasn't
always lucky Dennis told you the story
of how they sold their wedding presents
in order for them both to come to
America there's a there's a follow-on to
that
story which is it still wasn't enough
money so they went to the local casino
half an hour outside of tucumán I tried
to find the best odds that could give
the closest odds I could get to have
50/50 chance which obviously still
wasn't quite that and they put all the
money down that they were either both
gonna go and either was gonna go and
they lost hoping for that miracle they
still lost they decided that Caesar
should still go and he did and several
weeks later
Deanna's aunt in Mexico City heard the
story and sent enough money down so she
could come join him which was a good
thing because she then announced she was
pregnant so they were starting a life in
many ways starting a new life in in in
America he always marveled at where his
adventures took him going to University
of Illinois from northern Argentina's
not knowing anybody it's a stranger he
marveled that the openness and the
generosity and how one thing led to
another and the Dean of the architecture
school had a friend John dink Lou who
recommended him for a job and he came in
and worked for sarin and there he was a
few short years after coming to this
country with nothing knowing no one
there he was working on the TWA terminal
at this incredible practice for a finish
American architect with a brilliant
second in charge
Irishman Kevin Roche and he became part
of this community and this opened up
this world to him that he never imagined
didn't even know existed when he first
came to this country the other big
adventure of the when he left Los
Angeles he decided he wanted to be on
the East Coast yenna it had to move to
the east coast to teach and so he
decided to become an academic he took
the deanship at Yale thinking welcome
now I'm gonna be a teacher for the rest
of my life and I'm happy to do it I'll
have a small practice on the side months
after coming he got a major commission
then another and another and he ended up
with this practice that he never
imagined or predicted
but somehow the fates were lucky to him
in the larger cosmic sense even if he
had moments along the way beyond being
an adventurer he was a nurturing fun
father as Dennis already alluded to
always present very challenging as all
of you know who've spent time with him
he'll challenge your ideas and why
you're doing what you're doing but but
never dictating one of my favorite
memories of him was was the reading are
we read a lot in our family we read a
lot together in our family but at a
moment in his career when he was working
a lot traveling a lot he would still be
home every night to read to us now we
were not small children I was probably
11 and Dennis was 14 we were in separate
bedrooms which are diagonally across one
another and he would purchase share
between us lots of arguments about
whether he's closer to Dennis or me and
he would read to us including at one
point he decided to read the Lord of the
Rings god knows how many months that
took but we were riveted and we were
waiting every night to find out what
happens next
and those images from that time still
remember are very strong for me he was
an adoring Doering grandfather he saved
in the last few years as big as smiles
and his biggest praise for Cordelia and
iris he was also quite silly which many
of you may not have had a chance to see
that side of him he loved bad jokes bad
puns in particular he loved wordplay he
loved to sing but the singing he would
be the first to tell you it couldn't
carry a tune it had very little to do
with the melody he loved the lyrics he
loved were citing the lyrics and
primarily he gravitates
either towards silly lyrics or towards
wildly dramatic lyrics hence the tunngle
he loved the dongles because there's
nothing more dramatic than tunngle and
he would recite the stories of love and
loss that that you would have that you'd
always hear in the tango but as I think
of all the qualities that too
to me that most defined him were a
combination of qualities that often came
together there was a firmness to his
ideas there was always logic and purpose
to his decisions and that was coupled
with a generosity of spirit
everyone mattered he had time for anyone
his highest praise was that was a bit of
clear thinking or somebody was a clear
thinker that was about the most
complimentary thing he could say about
someone he wrote of himself I was always
good at making decisions hard but quick
ones and those qualities together
allowed him to be himself with anyone
with presidents of universities
presidents of countries CEOs students
and kids he always made time for kids
when they came by even in the middle of
work of a workday he'd always make time
for kids an old friend of my father's
who spent many years working with them
and they maintained a close friendship
even the years later years Carolyn
Morrissey who is here with us had a
great line about him which I'm I'm
stealing from her I'm borrowing with her
permission that he was an extraordinary
ordinary man yes and it captures so much
about him he would grill me about my
summer plans during college and if I one
year I proposed going on a summer travel
program and he gave me kind of a askance
look let's call it and proceeded to ask
well why and what do you think you're
going to get out of that and how does
this benefiting you and we spent quite a
couple days talking about why and
whether I should do it but then in the
end he he agreed but then it conversely
in 1976 he came to me and he asked my
permission to come to Yale
I had come here as a student I was very
happily 3,000 miles away from home the
kid from California which is still kind
of cool then at the Yale campus and he
knew I was happy to be independent so he
he didn't want to presume they came and
he asked me if it would be alright if he
accepted the deanship to come to Yale
and be head of the architecture school I
think he he'd leave me alone I took that
to be a rhetorical question but it was
very sweet of him to ask he would read
Scientific American religiously back in
the days and cover to cover then he put
aside that aside and read the Sunday
comics he siempre cmp don't leave it
with him I felt like a Lego tower when a
year ago my brother and I were sitting
with him and we asked him what would you
like for your memorial and he looked at
us with the big grin and he says I don't
care I'm not going to be there this is
for you do what you want it was clear
and generous at the same time and then
of course he laughed and laughed and so
many of you mentioned that today and I
have to say in the many hundreds of
notes of the letters I got if there was
one word that was the most commonly used
word it was laughter so I know usually
would be discreet around me so it wasn't
around me so much but I know all of you
who worked in the office particularly
would have your own imitation of Caesars
laugh and you would have contests to
have Jesus left so I can't think of a
nicer way to remember and honor him on
the count of three and I'm not gonna do
it because I can't imitate his laugh at
all but all of you together on the count
of three
to remember caesar one two three
he would have loved that Thank You Cesar
Thank You tato for living so well and
for showing us how to live well we love
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
following a brief blessing you're
invited to a reception which will be at
the Yale art gallery
I have special instructions for all of
you which is that you are to exit from
this door onto old campus and on your
way you are to pick up a flower you are
to carry it out the high street gate
down High Street turn right on Chapel
and there is a flower wall there robee
you'll be asked to place the flower
before you go into the reception we've
been here together for a brief time and
have shared stories and laughter and
perhaps a few tears so now we ask to be
sent out in peace to take this gracious
creative man's spirit with us into our
own lives and work be with those who
feel this lost most deeply comfort and
guide them and bless all of us to
Caesar's memory to go with us today and
always go in peace
[Music]
[Applause]